the American Cup is played under a
unique and exciting double elimination
format what is fun about it in Europe
actually this is my first time here uh I
changed my Federation like couple of
months ago so this is a like new thing
to me and uh I'm looking forward to it
this is a very interesting event it's
kind of different event I would say the
format is different and also even the
time control I do really like the format
it's a lot of fun and I think the
players also enjoy that it has different
time controls it's not just classical
chess oh I like this tournament knockout
system I think it's like very first
Spectators It's a Wonderful system it's
more interesting than around robin
tournament every game is very important
and for spectators I think it's it's
it's more interesting format for us also
I like something different I'm quite
excited to play in the American Cup I've
never played in this type of tournament
before where we have mix of classical
and Rapid how I like it I guess that
depends on how I do
so I will tell you that after the
tournament yeah so I think certainly the
world has changed a lot in terms of
Chess over the last couple of years a
lot of people in terms of the fans they
want to see quicker chess tournaments
that don't go as long as they have
traditionally
um so when you have a match format I
think this is a little bit of a template
similar to the fide World Cup which is
an event that's held similarly where you
have two game matches you have Knockouts
and you have an ultimate winner and I
think that when you have a format like
this where you do have a winner at the
end of the day and even if it's after a
couple of days of play nonetheless you
have someone winning when they're
playing head to head that's certainly
more favorable and I think the fans like
that so I'm pretty optimistic about the
format I think it should be a great show
for everyone I really enjoy performance
like this where you mix classical chess
rapid chest and even if it gets their
Blitz chest because it's like three kind
of different skill sets that a player
has to have well I'm a huge proponent of
knockout style tournaments in general I
think that's absolutely the best way to
run any individual sport uh just
included and so I'm delighted to be
playing this knockout event uh my big
dream would be four game classical match
as a knockout because this one does tilt
quite a bit towards Rapid and then once
you've lost you start playing rapid very
quickly for that but uh yeah I'm a huge
proponent of knockout events and I'm
very very happy to see that you know the
the best chess club in the world is
hosting knockout events now you know now
the second year in a row and I hope it
continues to be a tradition yeah well
this is my second time playing in it and
I think last year I was pretty confused
about the format uh now I have a better
idea of what it's about
um and I enjoyed it last year yeah it's
a fun format double elimination the nice
thing is that there's a second chance so
if someone has a moment of of weakness
or an accident that happens in one of
their games there's still a second
chance like a chance of redemption let's
say it's even stronger than last year
last year he covered in Play and now
he's joining and so all the best chess
players in the United States are playing
it's a genuine super tournament I really
enjoy playing in this tournament last
year it was a lot of fun I like the
double elimination at the World Cup
which is a single illumination it's kind
of said he lives early on and then you
have to live and go home so I like the
fact that everyone still gets a second
chance I really like the format I think
it's a it's very interesting format that
you have a chance to come back to the
tournament after being knocked out and
the field is extremely strong I'm happy
that Hikaru is playing this year it's
always nice to see him for me this is a
kind of a special tournament uh
for the first time I'm
playing tournament and staying in my
house you know in St Louis
this is something that I really missed
because I think last time I stayed in my
house and played and played the
classical tournament I was 19. so
it's a special field well I kind of like
the global elimination format it's been
it's become very popular lately online
also I just finished a tournament Berlin
also's double elimination so I like the
idea that it has two lives
that each player gets two lives
um then you get another chance and I
also like the match format I'm very
excited about this format that's my
favorite thing about American Cup
because I like that we play a match this
bracket and double elimination uh format
it's it's very exciting for us players
because we get to play one player twice
and really kind of measure our strength
with that one player and if it doesn't
work out we still have like uh you know
recovery uh that we can still get back
to the tournament compared to other
tournaments where you always play uh you
know one person just like with one color
and it takes forever here if you are in
good shape like just go go no one is
stopping you and if you are not then the
tournament is over so I think it's nice
for no matter what your uh current shape
this is the only tournament I've ever
played in with this format and I really
like it because
um I think that classical chess is
definitely like a great part of like
determining
um the result of matches based on
playing instruments but rapid chest is
like super exciting to watch for General
it's also very strong it's kind of like
the US Championship but with the
strongest possible players and
personally for me it's uh it's kind of
like the start of the season because I
took a long break from playing classical
chess so my last tournament was the U.S
Championship which was back in October
like ages ago it feels like so this is
uh the first time that I'll be playing
classical which is nice and I'm really
looking forward to it I was looking
forward for this tournament to be honest
I love it doublelon mentioned a lot of
like exciting moments a lot of
fun to have around and I I just like
this tournament in general it's just
like two chances and different formats
and four months in one tournament which
is great so this is one of my favorite
tournaments actually
thank you
foreign